[Music]
would a mega murderous universe killing
snap by any other name
sound as harsh after the shocking events
that played out in the final moments of
avengers infinity war
you know when thanos powered up the
infinity gauntlet then snapped his
fingers and wiped out half of all living
creatures across
every galaxy in existence marvel fans
have been at a loss as to what to call
the mad titan's horrifying act
while most people have referred to it as
the snap or by the more creative name
the snapping
thanos is the only character who's
bothered to try to give it a name
law six stones i could simply snap my
fingers
they would all cease to exist and i call
that
mercy unless you're a genocidal monster
though that's not the best name to use
for it
for their part not even marvel has given
the moment a legitimate moniker
that is until now thanks to the
publication of the most recent avengers
infinity war tie-in novel the cosmic
quest vol 2
aftermath by brandon t snyder thanos's
snap has an official name
and it's a brutal one to those who
survive being snapped out of existence
by the mad titan
the act is known as the decimation while
the avengers and company clearly know
all the heartbreaking circumstances that
surround the moment
the vigilantes joining forces and
battles across the globe
several heroes making incredible
sacrifices and many crumbling away to
dust
some in each other's arms
non-superpowered humans spared by the
decimation won't know the truth
wait where did everybody go in the
cosmic quest vol 2 aftermath the
avengers have concealed the truth from
the rest of humanity
believing that revealing the fact that
thanos was responsible for taking the
lives of billions of people would hardly
help the world to heal
no one but earth's mightiest heroes and
the band of marvel vigilantes involved
with the event
know what actually happened everyone
else is only aware that most people in
the world have vanished without a trace
and aren't aware of the reason why
something's happening
for comic book fans the name the
decimation should ring a big bell
in the marvel source material the
moniker was previously employed to refer
to the aftermath of the event that
happened in the house of m storyline
which featured scarlet witch stripping
powers from 90 of the world's mutants
the de-powered mutants suffered terrible
fates after scarlet witch wiped away
their abilities
with some fading away and eventually
dying without their powers
though it's fitting that the cosmic
quest vol 2 aftermath would pluck the
decimation name from the marvel comic
canon
given its similarity to the aftermath of
the house of m event
it remains to be seen whether marvel
studios and directors joe and anthony
russo
will implement the name in avengers 4 or
if the heroes will
as they have done in the comics and this
new companion novel keep thanos snap a
secret from humans
thanos's snap and scarlet witch's power
clearing in the house of m storyline
are incredibly similar to one another
and it makes total sense why the heroes
who made it out alive would want to save
others from the trauma of the full story
but will fans hear that name and witness
that secret keeping in avengers 4
we don't feel like we're reaching and
saying that it's possible but knowing
marvel
anything can happen marvel has a
tendency to keep any and all avengers
related details in near impenetrable
lock boxes
so to make any confident declarations
about the contents of avengers 4 would
be silly
at the end of the day fans can find out
what thanos snap will be called in
avengers 4
when the film opens in theaters on may 3
2019